Якби на Землі було пекло, воно виглядало би саме так.
Полум’я знищило те, чого не зробили дві світові війни, зруйнувавши понад 800-річну історію.
За падінням шпилю Нотр-Дам де Парі у пекельне полум’я спостерігали у Франції та в усьому світі.
Тисячі людей зібралися неподалік у Парижі - шоковані масштабом пожежі.
Серед них - і президент Франції Еммануель Макрон.
Цей собор ми змогли побудувати понад вісімсот років тому.
І протягом століть вдосконалювали його.
Тому я офіційно заявляю: ми відновимо цей собор, усі разом.
Можливо, це частина долі Франції і наш проект на найближчі роки, якому я відданий.
Тому ми розпочинаємо національну кампанію зі збору коштів на реставрацію.
Близько 400 пожежників боролися за те, щоб вберегти головні дзвіниці церкви.
І ризикували своїм життям заради порятунку релігійних реліквій та безцінних витворів мистецтва.
Полум’я дуже швидко розповсюдилося дахом. Усе через дерев’яні балки, датовані 12 століттям.
Проте є і хороші новини: основні елементи структури собору - врятовані.
Це втрата не лише для французів, але і людей в цьому світі.
Незалежно від того, католики, віруючі чи ні, усіх нас єднає відданість Собору Паризької Богоматері,
тому що це - віха, місце для укриття у французькій історії.
У Нотр-Дам де Парі ми збиралися і в горі, і в радості протягом усієї нашої історії.
Це кінець епохи, частини історії та архітектури. Це надзвичайно сумно.
Це те, за чим тужитимуть в усьому світі.
Свої співчуття Франції висловили у багатьох країнах,
а низка меценатів вже пообіцяли виділити кошти на реставрацію Собору.